did you know that only 9
of business owners in the united states
right now are utilizing youtube to grow
their business
business owners you are missing out on
an incredible opportunity to reach your
target audience to sell more of your
products and to make an impact in your
communities and on today's grow with
video live show we're going to be
talking all about the seven steps the
seven things that one business owner has
used to exponentially grow his business
reach more people and has been able to
grow a youtube channel to over one
million subscribers we're covering all
that and more in today's grow with video
live show
[Music]
welcome back to the grow with video live
show my name is heather torres one of
the hosts here at think media for this
show and i am so fired up because we are
going to be diving all into
business on youtube now if you are just
getting started as a business owner
maybe you are in the financing space or
real estate space or maybe you are a
craftsman like today's guest you are
going to want to be locked in for this
episode because we're going to be
talking about seven ways that you could
be growing your youtube channel and why
you need to be using youtube right now
as a business owner and here's the thing
you don't need all the fancy gear and
all the lighting and a huge youtube
studio all you need is a smartphone to
get started and i'm going to be sharing
more about that with you today today i
am
today i am going to be bringing on my
guest who is mike quist from stone coat
countertops is the company that he grew
and we're gonna be talking all about
that but a little background is mike is
the husband of 19 years to his wife
catherine and he is a father of four
sons he's a contractor an entrepreneur
an author an artist and a motivational
uh speaker mike and catherine started
multiple businesses including kitchen
and bathroom remodeling cabinet
manufacturing granite slab countertops
and are known worldwide for the largest
consumer epoxy company stone coat
countertops mike and catherine
they've become world famous on youtube
with over
250 million views 1.4 million
subscribers and they built stone coat
countertop from their dining room table
their living room and they generated
over 100 million dollars in revenue from
their business mike cares more about his
uh his wife and his kids and he's
dedicated right now to free time and i'm
so excited because he's gonna be sharing
some knowledge today about the seven
tips for growing on youtube as a
business owner so welcome to the show my
quiz thank you so much heather and i
really appreciate that intro and i
appreciate uh your your relationship
since day one thank you so much for
having me on this on this channel
it is my pleasure and i love that we get
to interview our success students you
know mike you've been a part of what
we've been doing here at think media for
almost half a decade now i mean i feel
like you were one of our starter
students and you've really grown with us
and it's been incredible to see
what you and your wife have been able to
create uh from the power of youtube so
why don't you tell everyone just a
little bit about your story because i
think it's fascinating that video has
been something that you really jumped on
early on and you had no clue what you
were doing right absolutely no clue i
started with a flip share camera if
anybody remembers what those were and uh
we actually started in our dining table
i didn't know how to turn on a computer
and i knew that my before and after
pictures for original clients really
helped sell our our services and then
doing home shows i realized that playing
a video of our services was even better
and then i would hand out dvds that we
burned and then i realized i don't like
burning dvds i found out about youtube i
said i could send a link instead of
burning a dvd and our close rate for all
of our sales really went up as we sent
our bids with these links to to what we
did and then i realized i was getting
these inquiries from all over the
country
hey can you come do my project and i'm
going no i i can't fly to you know
wisconsin to do your project however it
let me understand why don't i teach
people what it is i'm doing uh offer the
same products that i found over
10 15 years of searching for the right
methods and the right the best practices
and ultimately that led to selling a
product
accidentally through youtube but
understanding the power of video by
searching out realizing that if i made
better video content uh with with a real
purpose-driven um idea and and i learned
how to sell uh act like a lamb cell like
a lion when i learned how to do this
through video by people like heather and
sean it it it definitely changed the way
we think about business and changed our
entire trajectory um forever
yeah it's been incredible to watch your
journey and uh i love that you didn't
even know how to use a camera um
what i love so much about when you go
and you watch uh what you've been able
to produce on your channel uh you know
you do keep it really simple still it's
not like you're you know uh high
production you really are keeping it
simple so that other content creators
just like you can keep it simple
absolutely you know we started getting
down one of our goals a few years ago
was to be better than diy network or
better than hgtv and we produced some
very high high quality videos and went
went for the moon with it and to be
honest they were still base hit videos
in a lot of respects and and people care
about authenticity they care about the
the information they care about um what
we learned is they care about the 10x
rule what we call that is you save them
10 times their money you save them 10
times their time or you make them 10
times their money if you do one of those
three things
the quality of our video didn't matter
nearly as much as those three principles
i want to jump into these tips but man i
just love seeing what you guys are
creating over on the stonecoat channel
let's jump into tip number one though
and this is these are your tips that
you've used over the last uh i would say
probably seven eight years of as you've
been growing this channel and number one
is that you want to give away
massive value surrounding your business
and you know this holds a lot of
business owners back right they think
well if i'm giving away for free what do
i charge for so why don't you break down
this and why this is a tip for business
owners
uh you have to give to get i learned
that from actually watching think media
and gary vaynerchuk and channels like
that i learned that if i watched think
media and i learned a specific principle
about a camera i could actually buy that
camera i could go up learn how to use it
implement what i was taught and that
increased my revenue when when i learned
something that that was that valuable to
me for free the moment that you guys had
your first grow with video live event my
wife and i were probably with the first
ones to buy tickets like we we were so
thankful for all that free information i
couldn't wait for what you were charging
for i've i copied that same principle in
our businesses we're gonna give away all
the information that took me 15 years to
figure out maybe even longer than that
and i just simply gave it away to the
internet somebody wants to give it away
the information wants to be free if you
choose to be that person you create a
loyal audience that can't wait to
support you when you have your product
your service your event whatever that
may be
yeah and i think you know one thing
that's so important is that mind shift
of moving the free line of what you're
doing and you know as a contractor as
someone who makes your money from
actually going to clients um what was
that fear like for you at all when you
got started with giving this away for
free
it was massive fear i i my wife and i
didn't want we would go to home shows
our booth would be massively packed and
which was like we won the lotto people
were at our booth they wanted to buy our
service but every other contractor at
these shows would come over and say how
are you doing this what what are you
doing how did you make that and we were
hiding it we were hiding it close to our
chest in fact i made um a dvd set and
and the dvd set was all the tips tools
and tricks of how to do these
countertops that i learned how to create
but i was charging two thousand dollars
for these dvds in two years i got one
person to buy that set of dvds they
liked what i was doing but they didn't
know how much value was in those dvds so
i got one person to buy it they bought
one kit from me in two years i got so
frustrated heather i took all of my
samples in my shop and i literally had a
bonfire outside on the gravel i was
crying i was broken i was i was beat up
i gave up and my wife thank goodness
said don't give up i actually went
through that temper tantrum twice i did
it again a few months later and finally
when we started giving away the the same
videos i made i published on youtube for
free
that's when our business actually
started and took off it's incredible and
i love that you know sometimes it just
takes those those moments of frustration
right sometimes it takes those moments
of am i doing this right are we going to
make this happen and then all of a
sudden right you start seeing this
massive success and i just want to play
just a little bit of some of the early
videos so that people can see you know
this is not hdtv but i think it's
actually better than hdtv talk about
what what this type of video was for you
i mean who's videotaping it what does
this look like uh and and you just
started putting it out for free
yeah this this was just one of our um
simple remodel videos that i made for
customers that i'm kind of talking to
people but i just had my my helper i had
one guy working for me and and he would
go around and film and i would talk and
and this is before we even remodel the
kitchen we're talking about what we're
to do but when you bring people behind
the scenes and what it is that you do
they see
you they see you as a real person it's
not over um edited where it shows the
process and procedure they know a my
place is going to become a mess that's
okay they know they s it sets proper
expectations but honestly they get to
know you people buy from people they
know like and trust when they know you
and they trust you and they see all
these other people that have used you
people are also sheeple they'll follow
the crowd if they know you've had one
million people click on a video they're
more likely to click on that video
that's what that vanity metric is used
for is that confidence builder and so
that's what those original videos they
simply closed the deal for me i didn't
have to sell on site i learned
that number one sales is extremely
important in this business but number
two i could do the best sale i possibly
could i could edit it i could get it out
there for my customer and when i got to
the house all i had to do was measure
and play them my my my sales video and
and it closed the deal oh it's so
amazing you know last week we actually
had levi who's a real estate agent in
dallas so if you haven't watched that
episode make sure to go back and watch
it and and what he said was we have
people that already know they want to
work with us because they've watched our
youtube videos we're not having to
quote-unquote cold sell
and run advertising we're doing this
because youtube is bringing the right
customers to us so same thing in your
business let's get to tip number two
which is become a practitioner of
getting attention on
youtube i think this is something you
definitely have mastered mike because
stone countertops
has over 247
million views on that channel
and i would love for you to break this
down why is this so important as a
business owner to understand i love how
you use the word practitioner meaning
this is something that you are studying
and you're using and you are seeing all
the ways that you could get more
attention
yeah practitioner is it you have to you
have to constantly be studying this
because it changes it changes
monthly daily weekly yearly if you
aren't on your game if you don't
understand what humans are looking for
today it wasn't the same especially
it's that statement's never been more
true than it is now you know i learned
that the think media girl with video
live is people have uh less attention
than a goldfish you know if you know
goldfish can pay attention for nine
seconds we're less i learned about hook
i learned about title i learned about
thumbnail i understood that if i don't
get you to even you first is your
thumbnail if they don't click on it if
they don't glance over to the right and
look at that title i could make the best
video in the world if i don't learn how
to grab your attention you know gary vee
talks about his lemonade stand he would
watch where people's eyes went when they
were driving through an intersection so
he knew where to put the booth that is
extremely true today i think people
overthink sales they overthink these
things they they they kind of invest in
a lot of artificial intelligence it's
not that complicated if you wouldn't
click on that thumbnail if you wouldn't
like that title if you're not searching
what your title says stop listening to
ai so much and start implementing common
sense common sense isn't so common but
if you implement that if you understand
just the simple rule if i wouldn't click
on that video if i wouldn't watch that
ad in its entirety why do i expect other
people to do so and so that's
and then i just look at our analytics i
mean we we have the ability to look at
metrics from other companies as well
that are public and if you don't study
those and understand and don't get
jealous because they beat you understand
why they beat you and get better at it
you know that's that's i guess that's
how i would start that uh that's how you
become a practitioner i love it and you
know i i think one thing for business
owners specifically or entrepreneurs or
or people who are doing something you
are a craftsman by trade and so the idea
of becoming a youtuber right or becoming
a content creator you had to find the
time to be able to make that possible
talk to me just a little bit about what
that looked like for you because you
were also still running a business you
have four sons you you know you're doing
all the wrestling things and life is
full and i know that when people are
challenged with the idea of becoming a
practitioner of something that really
it's the time that people think will
hold them back so just give me a little
bit about what that looked like for you
um as a busy entrepreneur trying to
figure this out to become a practitioner
well you know you're the queen of
calendaring right you gotta you gotta
you gotta decide what it is that you
taught us about income producing
activities we took that to heart i
learned from ed mylett the three
six-hour days so you have you break your
day up into 18 hours and you you you
literally plan each six hour day you i
don't over plan i put the bullet points
of what it is i'm gonna do and i start
with number one and when when that six
hours is up i go to the next one and
i've done that for so many years now
that i do it automatically and and you
know if you do that you get about 2.2 to
2.3 times the amount of information uh
done in a day that your competition will
and if they're not focused on the ipa
the income producing activities you're
leaving them in the dust so if you if
you hustle um number one heather i had
to overcome addiction i had to get over
the addiction i had to get over the
things that were holding me back my wife
and i had to learn to work as a team we
had to learn what our lanes were but
we had to make a choice do we want to
continue being contractors and go down
that road we had to give up
a lot of work and that wasn't in my
nature i couldn't do it all i had to
walk away from a cabinet job that was
the biggest bid i ever give forty
thousand dollars i worked on this bid
and finally two years later they came
back and said yes we'll take your we'll
take your cabinets and by that time
stone coat was in its third month the
first month we did 300 in sales the
second month we did 3 000 the third
month we did 26 000 in sales so then i
was at a crossroads do i build this
cabinet job and put stone coat aside
because it's 40k
i had to tell them i wouldn't do it that
was the hardest decision but that same
month we did 40k at stonecoat the next
month we did 70k and it just went from
there it went crazy but if i didn't make
that decision once you get that momentum
you know how important it is to not lose
that momentum so it was a choice it was
planning it was three six hour days and
it was working our ever loving tells off
that's what it was oh i love it so much
and uh thank you so much for saying that
you learned a lot of it at growth video
live mike growth video live is in just a
few short weeks it's coming up uh we've
got it may 23rd 24th and we actually
have a bonus day for business owners we
are be we are hosting a platinum day and
today's video is brought to you by our
grows video live platinum ticket at gwvl
gwvlplatinum.com
and this is a day where we are going to
be having a smaller group of like-minded
business owners and entrepreneurs who
are ready to learn the secret levers of
success for uh for other business owners
who are winning with video just like
mike who was able to scale his entire
youtube channel but not just youtube
channel his entire business with these
different levers that are happening on
video this is not just youtube this is
tick tock this is uh video internal
inside of your uh company and this is
all the social media platforms that you
would want to use to grow your business
so if you would like to join us for that
third day at growth video live and get
access to a networking party get access
to like-minded individuals and to be
able to learn from guest experts like
alex and layla hermosie you can get
access to that by going to
gwvlplatinum.com and we want to give you
five percent off of that ticket when you
use the code gwvl show because you are a
listener and watcher of this show so you
can get access by going to gwvlpla
and we cannot wait to see we're going to
be hosting it this year at the m resort
in las vegas so you can fly in come stay
at the resort be a part of what we're
doing and as a platinum ticket holder
you will also get the opportunity to
take a photo with gary vaynerchuk and
patrickbetdavid two of our featured
speakers at grow with video live this
year you can get all access at growth
video live go to gwvl
and i cannot wait to share more about
what that is like and and uh you might
have been to our conferences um i
remember the first one that you came to
and and uh i remember you told me it was
life-changing for you encountered the
things that you were learning
absolutely it uh it's it's undersold and
you guys undersell and overproduce the
things that you the action items that
you gave us
literally we implemented them we still
do to this day and being in that small
table i sat in that small table and the
people that we met
um actually those relationships uh was
what i think we took away from that
we've kept in touch my wife has kept in
touch with people from these masterminds
of yours that have become lifelong
friends but but we've helped one another
and
honestly that investment that return on
investment of what we learned at those
events and who we met and the shoulders
that we rubbed you know you become a
product of the five people you associate
with most when you put yourself in those
rooms and you're a sponge and you take
that stuff in
and you also give back the unlocks that
people can give to others create these
lifelong friendships that are real i i
didn't anticipate going to these events
and making friends that wasn't my goal
but that was obviously a consequence of
it and it changed our business in so
much that
it made us millions of dollars i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna beat around the bush
it made us millions and millions of
dollars from the information that we
learned i remember uh listening to
celine johnson and one of the biggest
things that she told my wife and i we
walked up to her and her husband after
she presented and we said how do you
guys work together and she said
something so simple she said we've
created lanes and we've learned to stay
within those lanes and because of that
we're extremely happy on our business
and our marriage and that changed my
wife and i's life forever but it also
helped us learn how to be a chief and an
indian and uh the things that we learned
from owen video he was in that group
with us that the friendship that we have
with him and and the support that we we
love him and and and and um a a young
lady who worked for v we learned a lot
about his business and how that started
and my goal was honestly to have a
bigger
trajectory than gary vee did when he
built his wine business and i got to
tell you heather we do so when you when
you see garyvee say i know someone who
beat your trajectory because we did we
started from zero and we grew that thing
to a nine figure business um in in in
six years so we were very stoked about
that i mean incredible to see what
you've been able to build because of the
power of video and i can't wait for you
to be a part of growth video live this
year we are offering both in-person and
virtual experience for this so more on
that to come but let's get into tip
number three mike and that is build
content that leads to a marketing
funnel we don't want to just be creating
content for content sake right we're not
just trying to grow you know just our
own egos we are making content to go
into a marketing funnel why is this so
important for business owners
you know something that i learned from
sean actually in watching one of his uh
older videos was have a thumbnail and
title picked prior to even starting your
production which i always did opposite
of that but that that makes you think of
what's the purpose of this content now
it doesn't have to be a greedy purpose
but if you're not getting somebody to
another piece of your content if that
funnel doesn't take them to another
video or a landing page or or something
that grabs their email so you could
remark it to them grabs their text maybe
you help them in another freemium where
you give them a checklist so that they
don't forget how to template countertops
or whatever it is that i was teaching
you have to understand that if one of
your videos goes viral organically this
is what we did heather this is this is
the biggest secret i could give your
audience is the algorithms want to be
used for what they were designed for
they were designed for ads they were
designed for ads if you have a product
to sell that means you you should have
an ad budget if you're selling something
we took 20 of our gross volume and we
put it back into advertising and i
learned that if something went
organically viral and i determined that
viral on uh where we were i didn't
compare myself to think media i compared
myself to where where was i that week if
our average video view was 100 and we
hit a thousand i knew that it was
actually going out to more people
because the algorithm liked it i would
put a little bit of an ad budget as that
thing started to taper back down and
when when i did that it it actually
closed the deal if i had a
purpose-driven piece of that content if
it was driving them to my website or to
another video or to another piece of
stone coat that they that they would
eventually lead to a sale because we all
know
a lot of people don't buy on the first
impression they need five 10 15
impressions when we got them to the next
impression and it did its job we learned
that our revenue went up and i didn't i
didn't need that instant gratification i
didn't need to say hey look we we got a
sale because of this video i just looked
at our gross volume and i knew the
better video that i did the more
impressions that i put out to people the
more that i paid that algorithm to show
people my content the more sales we made
i kept it simple i didn't overthink it i
and honestly i i hired some agencies
that did kind of overthink it and when i
did it actually went down when i
realized you know what make good content
that leads to the next step and if i did
that right i would make more sales i
didn't overthink it i took 20 put it on
and that grows with you at scale if you
go 20 percent and and and your your
overall sales is a thousand and then it
goes to 100 000 your ad budget goes up
and you grow and it compounds and you
get to 1.14 million subscribers that's
how
oh come on that's like a free master
class in five minutes of exactly how to
use the algorithm right and melissa said
mind blown great information yes
you're learning from
real life entrepreneur who's using the
algorithm the right way and i love how
you said this you're like don't actually
overthink it like it doesn't have to get
super crazy technical you can learn this
stuff super easy on youtube and here's
what you're doing
you're producing great content and then
right here our store and products
click this link right and you're saying
inside of this video like down below you
can click the link and then they click
the link and voila they're headed over
right to your site to be able to
purchase right on the site right off of
what you're actually teaching them from
this epoxy master class it's incredible
what you guys have been able to build
and you know this video is an hour and
30 minutes you have sun videos on your
channel that are shorts now at you know
less than 30 seconds and you've got
other videos that are 10 minutes long so
you're mixing up the content also um
trying to find what is working for
people and here's what i also love too
you talked about this a little bit
earlier you said choosing the thumbnail
and the title before you even get
started because this is your top of
funnel when you're creating a marketing
funnel youtube is the top of that so
that's the first thing they're gonna see
as they go through that journey as a
customer who wants to buy eventually if
you're getting value out of this right
now and you're watching live click that
like button and if you know an
entrepreneur who needs to be hearing
this information i want to encourage you
to share this video out with uh with the
link here on youtube to help other
people learn how to use youtube number
four mike we're gonna this is kind of
the second part but number four you
wanna build your remarketing list
through your content talk a little bit
about this because
uh i hear this so much the fortune is in
the follow-up right so people are on
youtube they're watching all your videos
they're doing all this but remarketing
is actually
huge when it comes to getting someone
because they need to see something more
than one time before they make a
purchase so how did you utilize this to
grow your business to over nine figures
if you if you rely on the algorithms
being your best friend you're gonna find
out that facebook all of a sudden stops
putting any of your content out to
all of your friends and now it's like to
10 people they'll change overnight if
you don't own that audience if you don't
have a way to connect with them and say
you know what i actually like
instagram this week better go check out
this instagram post if you can't connect
with them and honestly
if you look at banner ads 15 years ago
people actually clicked on banner ads if
you look at email lists
10 years ago people open the majority of
their email people get over advertised
to so you have to again become a
practitioner of how you connect with
people um right now i would say that
text
sms like that is a really smart move if
you you know i look at all of my texts
if you have my phone number that means i
i like you enough to have shared that
with you people share their email far
more than their their own phone number
so the way that you can build your list
to remarket it needs to be up to date
and current you can't you can't just say
okay i watched this video from five
years ago and this is how to do it be
current of what's the easiest uh less
most least amount of friction to get to
somebody and then don't
over
don't waste their time bring them value
with each and every thing that you you
send to them if i get a bunch of emails
in my email box that i know aren't
aren't that valuable to me i'm gonna
quit opening it so i was very careful at
how i did remarket but when i did it was
purpose driven i gave them value value
value value and then i asked for a sale
sometimes i wouldn't even ask for sale
i'd ask them to go watch something
different so
we built an email list of
well over a hundred thousand people
and we
anything that bounces we kill it it's
it's we keep that fresh we keep that
clean and that's a real email list we
built a facebook group um of over 85 000
people uh we we started doing the sms um
and and we we have ways that people can
get in touch with us that are our lifers
who have been with us from the beginning
we protect and we serve our customers
that have served us uh and and and and
support us so really build your
community in every way that you can that
makes sense and makes sense for your
brand yeah you know we don't own our
subscribers so we don't own our views
but
it is a free way for us to get in front
of the right people that do want to go
deeper with us and i one thing that i
tell new entrepreneurs that are starting
their youtube channels i always say have
a way for someone to go deeper with you
even if it's a free checklist even if
it's a um i love how you said the text
message i have a friend that she's
putting videos out and all she's asking
is if people want to get five free text
message reminders from her that will
help them in what she's teaching and and
so she's building her list because you
know like you said we don't own any of
this it's rented land but man i'm gonna
work this land right i'm gonna make sure
that i'm working this land and to have a
list of a hundred thousand people that
is where a new product comes you've got
a list when you want to launch a new
thing you've got a list when you want to
share someone else's products or someone
else in your community that you love you
have a list and people love to be a part
of communities where it's like-minded
and they want to go deeper with you so i
love that you said building that
remarketing list now
i actually think that number five
is probably the most important for any
business owner
when it comes to being in business right
not a hobby but being in business and
actually selling your products but
before we get into that mike i want to
just share this cool video of what
people can expect at grow with video
live
2022 this year this thing
is your gateway to get out of the thing
that you complain about but people would
rather complain about how it is than put
in the work we need to start
understanding how big this opportunity
is because for everybody in this room he
will sit back in 20 30 years and regret
if you didn't execute in this era it has
never been a better time in the human
race ever to actually just go all in on
you
regardless of what you're trying to
accomplish you've got to tell the world
about it this is now the world you're
not betting on this you're finished
[Music]
this is your golden era right now
there's never been a better time to be
here
[Music]
this is the
era of greatest
only business but life
i desperately want you to win
but this is on you
[Music]
oh growth video live is coming up in
just a few short weeks and for watching
this show and being a part of this if
you want to join us for our platinum
experience you can go to grow with video
live uh you can go to our
gwvlplatinum.com
and we have a discount code for you gwvl
show if you want to join uh into an
experience like mikequist had when he
came to grow with video live where
you're able to be in the room with
amazing business owners like alex and
layla hermosi sean cannell and so many
more you want to claim your ticket right
now for the virtual or in-person
experience at growth video live
at sorry gwvlplatinum.com
get five percent off because we want you
to have value but we want to jump into
number five i say we as if i'm in a room
with someone i'm not myself here mike so
it's you hey we're we're right here
we're right here heather we got this i
mean i would say your right here looks a
lot better than my right here i mean the
beautiful white background and just it's
just epic so um number five for any
business owner is you have to have a
fantastic product
that you believe in we don't want people
to just be selling crappy products mike
why is this important when you're trying
to grow your youtube channel uh as a
business owner
i've seen this a lot i've actually gone
to a lot of conferences i uh not not
just yours i've because we got so much
value out of your conference it actually
taught us to invest in ourselves in our
education we've we we hired mentors we
um invested into a lot of people that
are where were they were where we wanted
to be and um we we followed that advice
uh and we did it quickly we didn't sit
on our hands but what i went when i saw
a lot of people at these events a lot of
them were floundering and kind of
looking for
you know they knew they wanted to be a
youtuber but they they were kind of
forcing a a a round peg in a square hole
or vice versa and and i don't like that
i i think you need to have
serious expertise in something if you're
going to share it with people and and
say it's valuable don't
don't fabricate it don't be don't have
something generic actually know what it
is you're talking about if you're going
to be a business coach and you haven't
done a business there are way too many
people who are advertising that they
have information that's going to change
your life where ultimately they haven't
even done it and so
i know that sound i hope that doesn't
sound too rude but
i don't like that i'd say you know i i
was a contractor i worked with my dad uh
building homes and making windows and
and remodeling i i i served as his
helper as his as as his gopher i i was
in the trenches my entire life i learned
how to re i could teach somebody how to
remodel anything in a house i know these
countertops that i teach i know
everything about a kitchen not just the
counters i i helped our customers with
their plumbing over the phone because i
knew how to do it i wasn't just
kind of peddling a product and and
i tried everything every product in my
niche in so much that i worked with the
chemist hand in hand to make sure we had
the best i didn't just quickly launch
something i know there's people who've
done that successfully but i would say
when you're when you're truly an expert
at what you know sean says and i've
lived by this overnight success takes 10
years if you
if you work in the trench
and you know that you have to be an
expert in this thing and you become that
expert then by all means share it and
have a product that you truly believe in
because if you don't the internet is a
small neighborhood your reviews are
everything and and you can't lie on
facebook and google reviews those are
real customers you can't lie on amazon
reviews those are real customers the
reviews have become what everybody looks
at to see if you're lying and when you
tell the truth you know my book is how
how i made a million telling the truth
on youtube when you tell the truth and
people get their your product they're
gonna test it they're gonna test it and
when you tell them the truth your
reorder rate is phenomenal and so that's
what we based it on as stuff that i knew
about that my wife knew about we didn't
lie to anybody we didn't pretend it was
better than it really was and we uh
undersold and over produced and we also
invested in our team like you wouldn't
believe that supported our product we
didn't leave our customers hanging where
they didn't have the information they
needed to be successful with it
as a business owner you got to have a
product that you believe in and that you
know and that you are uh that you are
actually um able to help people and i
love i love even the the authenticity of
what ryan said ryan's one of our success
students inside of video ranking academy
is coming to gross video live this year
virtually and he said that's where i'm
at right now i'm trying to figure out
what product i have to offer that i can
believe in and bring value and i think
it's really important to know that you
don't want to just be selling anything
you want to i mean if you want to be in
business in real business and not just
take people's money then you know you
business owners are an exchange of
knowledge and services for a profit and
so i love that that is such a huge
pieces you got to believe in what you're
doing because you know
going back to the uh beginning of your
story mike when you and catherine
started stone coat and you started
making these videos on youtube
uh millions of dollars were not coming
in at that point and so you had to
believe in your product and your service
to a such an extreme level that you had
to see what was unseen right
yeah yeah it's it's pretty it's pretty
important to make sure that that is uh
huge you touched on this we're going to
jump into number six which was build a
team based on performance and i'd love
for you to share you know what is the
team like uh your video side of the team
and how did you build that what was your
first hire and what did that look like
for you as a business owner going into
the content space and really growing
that youtube side of your business
originally it was just me learning how
to use wondershare filmora learning how
to use windows movie maker was the first
thing that i used on that flip share
learning learning how to just make a
simple cut honestly your your channel
think media is is what i would go to as
my learning um channel that's how i
learned to edit and what cameras to buy
and all actually the biggest thing that
made a difference to me is why i became
a think media um a fan was because sean
took a little bit of time out of his day
to reach out to me and help me uh that
nobody else knew about he didn't get
paid for it and he didn't he didn't tell
anybody about it he did it just out of
the kindness of his heart and that's
when i knew
if i don't do that for other people i
won't build those lifelong relationships
i did that for other people by examples
like that and so the team that we built
was based on need i was i was literally
sometimes editing 24 hours straight
knowing that i had to get content out to
sell more product because the more the
better content i got out the more our
sales went up and so
sometimes i sit in a chair for 24 hours
sometimes longer editing video i'd make
the video i'd edit the video i knew i
needed help and so i started running ads
for a video uh creator somebody who had
experience and knew how to do these
things and the people that are
interviewed
they weren't um a good fit for me i'm a
very type a personality i'm very
particular um sometimes hard to work
with and i knew i didn't want to
surround myself on a daily manner with
somebody who might be a negative
situation and actually had a blessing
where um a friend of mine who was
working in our shipping department he
said hey i saw your ad mic and i came in
and and i wanted to to interview for
this job i said well chris do you know
how to edit he goes well i know how to
edit i go do you know how to film do you
have you ever used he goes no i don't
but
the biggest thing that he told me was
but i'll learn how and i said okay
you'll learn how and i had just bought
because i bought it through your amazon
link on think media was a canon 70d
and that's back when that was the the
best camera kind of for my situation and
i gave him this camera i said chris you
can't you can't break this camera this
is all i could afford don't mess it up
he's like i won't mess it up he took
that camera home over the weekend he
came back and like a marine with his
rifle he knew how to disassemble it he
knew every function he knew how to use
it the kid was a computer whiz but he
was working in our shipping department
i said hey i gave him the same test that
i gave the other people that we
interviewed for our editing positions
and he sat down there
and he did
better than they did in a shorter amount
of time and these guys won like the
sundance film festival and he did a
better job so
what i learned was if you build from
within if you teach people your system
your process your procedure we were
doing enough right that there was a lot
of value for whoever was on our team and
so i i gained confidence that not only
do i need you but what i have to give to
them would ultimately teach anybody that
worked for us in that capacity any of
your team heather could go out and start
their own multi-million dollar business
by the information they're learning
behind the scenes and that's what we i
brought to the table and they brought to
the table it had to be a good attitude
it had to be a a six hour times three
work ethic it had to be you know we we
call it the bamboo cage and i hope i'm
not taking too much time but this is
important there's a man who was shot
down over vietnam and he was put into
prison uh during the vietnam war his
plane was shot down he was captured he
was a civilian and he was put into this
bamboo cage and the bamboo cage didn't
allow him to sit up it didn't allow him
to really bend his knees it was a long
slender cage and he was in this cage for
seven years i read this story about this
man and he he was so distraught he he he
tried to kill himself through a rope
that they had on his neck he couldn't he
just made him pass out he was in such
a distraught manner
but but he ended up being being released
after the war he lived through it his
story was amazing but but sometimes
myself and my team would complain about
our seats on an airplane or we would
complain about silly things and i always
went back to if this man survived a
bamboo cage for seven years i could sit
in an uncomfortable airplane seat for
six hours and and so
learning those principles and and
teaching them and also becoming a
practitioner of learning um studying
motivation studying positivity studying
the power of positivity studying cells
studying what other people have done
that have have built teams that i want
to emulate is how i built the team that
i did and then i had to modify it
massively a lot of times um you know we
we would go somewhere and and go a
direction and it wasn't the right
direction it wasn't the right team and
and and what it became was my wife was
is the one who built our team we i
started sending people to her because
she learned from you heather how to
interview she learned from people like
you and sunny leonard doozy how to
interview and when she did that
she started getting the right people
because it was their why they they
started working for us because of their
why and their they were hungry and they
wanted to to be a part of something
instead of just have a job and when we
learn that and we learned how to
surround ourselves with people that we
wanted around us it made every like if
you're around negativity you're already
done you can't be around it it has to be
a positive atmosphere or else you're
you're you're gonna you're gonna
flounder
i mean bring in the fire that story is
incredible mike and you know we really
we we preach that i do definitely to our
team too we have we have an incredible
person on our team um who uh served in
the military was a sniper it was then it
was in in csi and so sometimes when i'm
sitting and i'm like oh my gosh my life
is so hard i'm like i'm also not sitting
in the middle of a desert holding a gun
that might have to end someone's life
like just the idea of the pressures and
just the the idea of you know you want
to surround yourself with the right
people but i love that you gave that
editor a chance and you know sometimes
you got to kiss a few frogs before you
find the prince you know and and the
idea that you don't even know where
those are going to come from you know we
we just uh did some hires here at think
media we actually doubled our team
because of of everything that's
happening with this brand and when we
went to go look for people you know we
hired internally we hired people that
have been a part of video ranking
academy that understand that we are the
rise and grind that we work hard when we
work hard and we play hard and we play
hard but that we're on a mission and
we're not just here just to get a
paycheck but we want to impact people's
lives and and i think it's really great
that you brought even just that culture
of just even knowing the type of people
you want to be around when you're
building your team so it's super
important that um you know you're
building that team i love how you said
to based on performance like you're not
just giving out a paycheck to give a
paycheck
this is about being on mission and
understanding that even through
craftsmanship even through video
creation that you're changing people's
lives and that this becomes an impact in
in society in a good way so i love uh
that you're building teams and and i
also there was a key point that you said
there too um was you didn't do this
alone and i think a lot of times people
think oh yeah
i'm the only one that can do that no
there are people that can do it better
than you and so getting rid of the ego
and the idea that someone else is going
to do it better than you
i always say good i want that i want
someone else doing it better than me
because then i can focus on what i know
i've been called to do all right tip
number seven mike uh we're gonna bring
that up in just a minute if you're
getting value right now share in the
comments if you're watching live what's
been your aha moment so far mike i want
to say thank you before we get into
number seven thank you for being such an
incredible student thank you for being
someone who has supported us uh invested
with us has uh cheered us on has has
done life with us you know i think it's
so incredible that we've seen our kids
grow up together and it's just really
cool to be able to uh see this journey
and i appreciate you for your time i
know that your time is super valuable um
and so to me it's just an honor to be
able to to be here with you i love
seeing this that we've got some aha
moments happening in the chat again
you can get your ticket to growth video
live at
gwvlplatinum.com if you want to join
business owners like mike uh to go
deeper on a third day at our conference
and we've got a five percent coupon for
you but number seven i think is probably
the best way to end
this uh seven tips and that is you gotta
fail you gotta learn you gotta grow
right mike yeah absolutely fail fail
forward you know ev
i call it uh i studied successful people
and the common denominator success
defined as financially the common
denominator was
uh people who are successful make fast
decisions and they course correct as
needed if you're going to the moon in a
rocket ship you're only on trajectory
three percent of the time you always
have to course correct don't be afraid
to fail because every time you do you
learn something but you course correct
so fast that you mitigate the
consequence you learn from it you you
the the information that you could bring
in from a test and the beautiful thing
is is when i started advertising
i i started with 20 i didn't have to go
invest in a billboard in las vegas i got
to spend 20 bucks to see if it brought
me in a return on investment and when i
realized i spent 20 and made 200 that's
a pretty big roi okay how do we scale
that let's try 40 bucks and we got to do
it not in a gambling fashion but in a
learning and growing fashion after you
after you learn these things about your
business about yourself about what
worked for you
honestly heather i could look at any
product based business and i know this
sounds cocky i could learn it i could
look at any product based business and i
could look i could see immediately what
they could do to implement these things
to explode their business it becomes um
like a muscle that you've grown you've
worked out and you've done these things
so fast and so often that you could
implement them and we've started
many other businesses we've built a real
estate business with commercial real
estate we've done it with short-term
vacation rentals we built websites we've
i've started an art business i'm in
galleries we everything
is really like a cog that works together
when you learn these simple business
principles of how to use video to grow
your influence and ultimately your
audience that wants to support your
products when you learn these principles
and you learn how to use the tools the
windows like heather mentioned earlier
that right now
i may not own my youtube audience but
i'm definitely gonna use this
opportunity the window's wide open if
you keep jumping through the wide open
windows and you don't go slow you're not
afraid to fail you're not afraid to make
mistakes when you're when you get rid of
the fear and you just are testing and
also don't be afraid to say i got that
wrong i learned
say everything's my fault when you say
everything is your fault when you make a
mistake or anybody on your team or your
business makes a mistake then you learn
what you could do to fix it when you
blame it on everybody else around you
it's always their fault you can't fix it
so when you fail or your company fails
take it on yourself hey that was my
fault maybe i hired the wrong person
maybe i gave them too much
responsibility maybe i put too much on
an ad maybe i didn't look at the
comments well enough just don't be
afraid to fail
always be learning like if you're not
reading if you're not studying if you're
not like stop watching content that
doesn't move the needle for you if
you're wasting your time on videos with
cats playing with balls of yarn and
you're not studying personal motivation
or how to overcome your skeletons in
your closets if you're not constantly
just putting in the good you dwell in
what you dwell on
stop doing like we do this thing called
start stop continue
every time we we run a campaign every
time we we make a decision we look back
at that we go what should we start doing
what should we stop doing what should we
continue doing when you follow those
principles you have nowhere to go but up
you're always going to climb that that
mountain to success when you're
constantly auditing your performance and
and and be real about it don't be afraid
to be the dumbest one in the room i i
like being the dumbest one in the room
because that means i'm around geniuses
because i'm i've become pretty smart
heather i didn't i didn't learn how to
read until eighth grade i i was
literally in special ed classes i didn't
know how to read i i was very uh um
um scared to to to really fail i was i
was embarrassed of everything that i did
but when i learned that
i need to lean into my higher power i
need to lean into my loved ones i need
to i need to uh trust in the right
people and the right the right power
that's what that's what uh overcomes
that fear for god have not given us the
spirit of fear right so that's
that's uh that's where that's where i'll
go with that because that's really i
mean everything that we've been able to
accomplish
is because
we followed principles that are are are
not just temporal but they're also
spiritual
come on mike can i convert the people in
the back did you hear that one that is
so incredible and mike thank you for
being so vulnerable and sharing just the
entire story you know i think sometimes
we see people up and we put them on a
pedestal but just understanding that it
does it comes with the the learning and
the growing and the failing and the you
know looking at it twice and just so
amazing and thank you for sharing um
all of those pieces of what you're doing
uh and and and what an inspiring story
that you have um so incredible thank you
for joining us for joining me for
uh the growth video live show i like to
do this at the very end mike i think
it's super fun uh just for people to get
to know you a little bit more i'm gonna
do some rapid fire questions for you so
the first thing that comes to mind you
tell me what it is number one what is
one book every entrepreneur should read
um you know
this is a trick question and i knew you
were going to ask this but i'll tell you
a book i just read on the airport coming
home my wife and i went to we met some
youtubers and we become lifelong friends
with them we helped them we taught them
what you taught us and now we're life
artists till death we're lifelong
friends we went out to their wedding in
cancun mexico and at this resort this
resort was so incredible the service the
customer service the people the mexican
people were the most loving people
you've ever been around they were so
kind the everything was just perfect and
we're in the hospitality business now so
i'm like studying the rooms and why do i
feel so good they actually made their
steps one inch shorter so when you're
hiking their stairs you feel like you're
like in a different realm like very but
but i read the origin story of the man
who started this this this resort and i
read that entire book but i learned
that it's not always in the sales book
it's not always in the marketing book or
the business book you can learn these
tricks and this guy started it's called
escarte it's x-c-a-r-e-t
excaret or something like that i can't
i'm a gringo i don't know how to say it
but i'm also i learned so much from his
book and in it and it taught me what we
did right without knowing it and then i
study like this morning i'm studying
this book called the hawk method and
it's about marketing and it's about um
this company that uh that that knows how
to market but the the book that changed
my life was the millionaire next door
i learned about this guy who started a a
janitorial business
and
he was he was comparing that to
uh pro athletes and pro athletes got
over leveraged and an entourage and all
these bills the moment that he'd stopped
working they went bankrupt but this guy
who started a janitorial business oh my
goodness what it unlocked for me was
learn a trade
learn a skill that other people don't
want to do and if it's if it's changing
toilets by all means i'll change toilets
and and i got very good at changing
toilets and i got very good at building
a humble team in in the trades that
taught me the foundation of business so
the millionaire next door would be but
also search around like like re re read
the first chapter of a book and if it's
a waste of time i guess throw put it
aside don't waste your time but but i i
i love information i'm studying
information all the time
oh so good all right uh what was the
best advice you've been given as an
entrepreneur
gosh that's a hard one the best advice
whether you say you can or whether you
say you can't you're always right
um my mom my mom has been saying that to
me since i was a little little chubby
fat football player
uh one uh cool thing that you've done
uh since you have uh grown your business
to nine figures
i moved my family to hawaii so that i
could focus on my wife and kids um to a
degree that uh they deserve you know in
building our business we didn't have any
idea where it was going and it took me
away from my children and honestly um we
were able to sell our youtube channel
for over 25 million dollars and that
allowed me to not worry about money
anymore and allowed me to help people
and and that's what i'm doing i'm not
only helping my wife and kids they're
helping me but i get to
give of my time my talents and my
interest uh freely and and you know
denzel washington said each one teach
one reach back and help the people that
are trying to get to where it is you are
and i love doing that to people who take
action nothing frustrates me more than
giving uh the problem with giving stuff
away for free is people don't value it
nearly as much as if they paid for it so
i'm giving them million dollar nuggets
and they're leaving them in the in the
gutter uh and some of them that pick
them up and they do it i i mean this
this
this man that i'm working with right now
uh just a few things that again were
clear to me and now he's implementing
it's changing his life and that is now
what you say is your why that's become
my why
so so good all right last one uh what is
something right now you're doing that
you're excited about
i'm excited about my new youtube channel
am i allowed to talk about that
my new youtube channel is called just my
quest it's my name and i learned about
personal branding from from you guys and
honestly it's
i share
um
i share what's most important to me on
that channel and i love teaching my my
passion is business i love business i've
studied zig ziglar and tom hopkins and
brian tracy these original og sales guys
since i was a very young guy i mean
while other people were listening to
metallica i'm listening to zig ziglar
and like jogging to zig ziglar like i
love
uh understanding that information can
empower you and change your life and and
these principles they transcend all
business and so i'm sharing things that
i've been studying since i was a young
man um
and i'm doing it in a way for people
like me who are in the trades people who
are into art or crafts or or or you know
a lot of these people don't understand
how to use video like your audience it's
it's a different level it's a different
level my audience like when you guys
came and spoke at our event they hadn't
heard of think media but their minds
were blown and the line was out the door
to buy your course because they
understood the value of it and so
honestly i can't wait to share again
with my new audience well it's it's
people who are really just our lifers
it's like you you also taught you only
need a thousand people that believe in
what it is you're doing you don't need a
huge audience a thousand people uh
you're
you're you've
you you're huge at that point if you
truly have a thousand real fans so
that's what i'm excited about is my new
channel i'm i'm and and i don't know
where it's going but i i kind of do you
just you know build that audience and
give them so much value that when i do
decide where we're going to go with that
they'll support it
so awesome well mike thank you so much
for your time today thank you for all of
the knowledge that you've brought to us
what an incredible show i mean i'm just
blown away by just who you are the
impact you're making in the world um
just what you're building the legacy
you're leaving for your kids go ahead
what'd you say i just wanted to say one
thing because i i don't know if you're
going to end this and i just want to say
it before you do um when i came out to
you to one of your events
one thing that you and sean did is
you were afraid to get vulnerable which
gave me permission to understand that
people
like me for who i am and if i if i truly
share those things
that's where we change the world you
actually invited everybody who came to
one of your events
to uh sean was speaking at his church
and and my wife and i got on that bus
and what we learned from him getting
vulnerable what we learned going to your
congregation and the love and the joy
that you guys shared with each other
gave me permission to get real and to
talk about my real why and and and and
i want to thank you guys for doing that
for your entire audience i know i'm not
the only one who who sees that but it
changed my wife and i um that was
probably the biggest thing that ever
changed our life so thank you guys for
being vulnerable yourselves
wow well thank you mike i mean the love
is mutual both ways we're just inspired
by all that you're doing and um if you
would like to follow mike you can follow
him over on his brand new channel over
at mikequist uh on youtube and drop some
love like this video and um so grateful
for you mike for all that you're doing
and growth video live are you are you
pumped are you excited for this show oh
yeah oh yeah patrick by david alex mike
we've never done anything like this
every one of you when you were showing
your sizzle reel i'm going i love these
people oh my gosh i'm like i'm fired up
i got chills i'm like oh man like you
guys have a lineup that is strong the
only thing i'm mad about is i'm not in
that lineup so when i prove to you that
i become good enough you put me in that
lineup because i'll outspeak every one
of them bring it on heather let's go all
right well i am so pumped uh for growth
video live to see you in just a few
short weeks mike it's gonna be a reunion
like none other it's gonna be so
incredible but you can grab your ticket
right now uh
gwvlplatinum.com if you'd like to
upgrade to the platinum experience and
we will catch you in the next show make
sure you're subscribed here on the
channel like this video and we'll see
you in the next growth video live show
do you want to get in the room with
experts like gary vaynerchuk patrick
vette david vanessa lau pat flynn
chalene johnson and more and would you
like to meet hundreds of other creative
entrepreneurs just like you well then do
not miss the chance to get around
creators and business influencers at
growth video live 2022 conference you
can actually lock in your limited
discounted tickets at
growethvideolive.com or you can click
the link in this post or in the
description now if you want to learn the
best new strategies for getting views on
youtube and the most proven and
profitable ways to grow online then do
not miss this life-changing event you
can join us in person in las vegas or
virtually from around the world secure
your ticket at grossvideolive.com
and take the fast track to dominating
the next decade not just with youtube
but with video go to growthvideolive.com
or click the link in this poster in the
description to secure your limited time
discounted ticket